seis meses después de haber entrado en
vigor en la llamada ley del solo sí es
sí volvió al congreso de los diputados
de España que ha votado su modificación
la razón las casi mil rebajas de
condenas de agresores sexuales y las más
de 100 excarcelaciones que había
provocado la nueva horquilla de penas
que con la reforma del Código Penal
asociada a la ley eran algo más bajas al
unir abuso y agresión en un solo delito
la reforma de la ley de libertad sexual
aprobada hoy aumenta las penas de
delitos cometidos con violencia o
intimidación o cuando la víctima tenga
anulada su voluntad precisamente el
enfocarse en si había habido violencia o
no es lo que ha dividido a los socios de
gobierno psoe por un lado cuyas reforma
ha sido aprobada hoy y unidas podemos
por el otro que optaba por seguir
centrados en la falta de consentimiento
y no en la existencia de violencia para
determinar un mayor castigo ya que se
presupone que cualquier agresión sexual
es violenta de por sí Irene Montero la
líder del Ministerio de igualdad
perteneciente a unidas podemos ha dicho
hoy en la cámara baja que es un día
triste y que ha sido el más difícil que
ha vivido ella como ministra en el
parlamento las rebajas de penas podrán
seguir dándose hasta que esta reforma
entre en vigor un proceso que aún se
puede demorar unas semanas en junio el
tribunal supremo de España se reunirá
para fijar criterios sobre precisamente
la revisión de penas derivadas de esta